a couple Christmases ago I got this this
gift from one of our distributors who
sold me still sells us these incredible
nut oils from France from burgundy and
the maker did incredibly expensive this
guy's sort isn't like he doesn't in his
garage behind his house he knows guys
like another wackadoo and so he the
Frenchman the the artisanal producers on
mark Montaigne he gave the distributor
Olivier a present for us because we were
his biggest customer and his first I
think one of his first and he gave us a
gift for Christmas so Olivia handed to
me and I open the box and it's it's this
box of dust it smells a little bit like
nuts it's just dust I was like you know
what tells it so Olivia says I'll live
it you know John Mark wanted to give you
after he a present that that yeah of nut
dust is basically after he presses the
nuts for his oil he has all this residue
right so he said Olivia said you know
last year I went over to to burgundy and
I had lunch with jean-marc and as I
opened the door to go into his kitchen
he was there on the stove sauteing
potatoes and we sat down to to a salad
and and a little like fried potatoes so
I think potatoes but Olivier said all he
could taste from the salads potatoes all
he could taste were almonds he didn't
see any honest he just smelled this
overwhelming thing was we thought like
there was some kind of almond souffle
coming for deserves something and
there's no AMA souffle so he asked Ezra
Marcus agent Mark you know it's
delicious meal I'm tasting us almond and
Joe marks at all okay so after i press
the the almonds i have this residue this
this this dust is not destined stead of
throwing it out I throw it onto my
potato fields and a lot of it on my
potato fields and through this
incredible process of osmosis you know
he gets almond potatoes right so I
thought so he's telling me this and I'm
looking at my box sounds just like this
is the secret to you know my millions
right so I take the stuff and I called a
nut company
out in California and organic nut
company ask them for like 500 pounds of
I thought pine nut because I thought I
could one-up I'm I sort of got
competitive with this guy don't even
know who gave me a gift pine nut we did
we did and again we did walnut we got
all these nuts and and Jack spread them
on carrots and I didn't want to do it
with potatoes because i thought i would
be too much capacity carrots and we do
have a lot of carrots during the winter
so we spread spread spread spread spread
meanwhile I decide you know with my
brother we're going to make some money
so we do like this special night we know
when the harvest is coming seven weeks
after the plants going to say okay I'm
going to do a harvest night and we're
going to do on you know an almond carrot
night because we figured that would be
the one that worked the best almond
carrot night we invite the whole dining
rooms packed with people who are excited
i but we when we sent out this email we
talked to people for months and months
we get the waiters all jazzed up on this
thing I mean everybody was did the coat
check the valets everybody was the cook
Sara was talking about so the day of the
dinner comes right and and the harvest
for somebody came in really late that
afternoon and I hadn't actually really
tasted the carrot you know so it's like
430 and i'm bored sitting there cleaning
carrots and like I started to taste them
and right as I'm tasting them again you
know too too much to believe like the
tickets start coming in you know it's
like 50 min carrot salad 6 almond
carousels you know double order of Amun
carrots out and I take a bite of the
carrots no almond flavor nothing zero
zilch it doesn't even taste like there's
a potential for almond in the future
there's like nothing it's a delicious
carrot no almond total failure so I
slice the carrots you're like all of a
sudden tickets are coming in coming out
and got 30 tickets on the board and like
500 Amin south and so I started slicing
out the carrots really quickly salt
pepper lemon vinaigrette and I reach for
Jean Marc's almond oil of which i have a
few extra bottles and i start dousing it
with almond oil and i mix it and then i
give it to the waiters just to taste
before they go out the dining room
genius man it tastes like iming it's
unbelievable it's it's damn
barbers of genius you know so that night
we sell like 120 almond carrot salads
and it is the greatest success in the
history the best night we've ever had a
blue hill every episode ever had any
restaurant people
wrote emails they still talk about it he
was still talking about people say it's
the most exciting the most delicious you
know experience I've ever had in a
restaurant there was a buzz in the
dining I've never had and what I
realized at the end of the night in the
mayhem of plating all these salads I
mean it was crazy night I forgot to put
the almond oil in the in the carrots I
did on some but I didn't on a lot and it
did not matter it absolutely did not
matter people tasted almonds because you
told them the story and they tasted the
most delicious carrot of their life
because they had this funny story that
they felt invested in they felt a part
of and they wanted to be connected to I
think we're hardwired for this mess my
ultimate theory is like you know as
hunter-gatherers we were spending our
time figuring out is that thing
poisonous that thing delicious will that
thing feed our children you know is that
thing nutritious that kind of thing and
I don't think that's been bred out of us
you know so when someone gives you a
story of this kind of thing like it
informs us and relaxes us really to
taste things that we otherwise wouldn't
taste so that's my you know that's how
we have so many stories like that that
just like it teaches me again and again
you have a story you have delicious food
you know as long as you really don't
screw it up yet delicious so there you
go
you